BLAME.
ER.
NES WHHETHUK T
WAR, THE MAN WHO S IIMIR PUTIN.
RRYSC
INTEEN
X ERRENTANY.
TA RALLIEDEAN
PROVIDED MWEAPON
UKRAINE, A P S
HEIGHTENED ALERT TO SIGNAL
O PUBLICIZED THED WARFARE RUSSI
HAS
THSIRKUTBETTERMEASURURITEN
SI
INTERESTS D STRENGTH THIS CRISI.
ITRSWEAKNESSESS .K N ,
LOSE.
OWEN MEWWRITES IA PR
ENDENC
SEGMENT  TIO
NATIONTIBYO
OPEN CONICOINTS
TID
IAN NATIONALISM D FED OWTHELLIOF
PRN
ONBA T
THSTABLE ELECTIONS BEC
FROM A PLURALIRR NSTIMATEDINMESH
IN REDPECT IF
REO NSTABLE
ANT WOUL
SELE UKRAINE
THA KIND OFIFTH COLUMN WITHIN
ALWA URGINKYIV TO FORGE CLOSERSS
OUY NATIONALIST ME MUC.W, PUTINW
AND RE DEPDEBUT ALSO TO DIVIDE I
NCE
SR A POST COLRPOSE HAS
ERG FIPATCHING A F B THE
JETS TBULGARIAAN TROOPS IN ROMAA
UNDER NATOOM
DISPATCHING R
THE  8,500 TROOPS ON
NE EASTERN
MEEN ARE
EVENSIDERING
-EEU
THSTFICANT SUCCESS FORPUTIN S G.
RMANINITS EXPRESSED DOUBTSUT
AI
SERIOURD STR2, WHI
COULD SELLRMD THIS APPROAC A IN
TOUGH-MINDED INHER DEALINGSPUT
AN
BIMINISTRAONBEEN ALERT TIS PRO
TO BERLIAND INVITINGERKEL'R OLTO
WAGT AEEH
DEN.
WOBE WAR,
BEING DISCUSSED ART AG
WHIL
ANGE RVE
SI
L EXPORTS WOULE TH
WHWOUPON TNONG-HO
REGARD POSITIVELY.W, THIS DOESN.
N
BACKED INTO A CORNFIND THET FINA
DECA
SAIDHA R
MA ADDRESS THEAI
ISSUE BY WMESHIP IN NATOTRRAINES
UNLIKELY TO BECOME ANYTIME
UNS  CONSENS THEAGREEMENT ON THR
IBILITY AT UAIO AT SOME IN
E O REALITIES LIRROWRIOR
CRMACY TT WAR THOUES YEARS.
TO M"WASHINGTON POST" COLUMN
THISEEK.
AND LET'S GET O KEEP A
RUSSIANDKRINING ME NOW EXPERTS H
IN THOSEESNEOTPLE STOR,
AN OEIGN PY HES, TECNERAL OF RN.
NA GUMENAN
JOURNALIHOTS O
CONFLICT AND INA
GOEDN UKRAINE  COULD BE AN INTE
FIRST SHOCK A F AGO PEOPLE WER
BEISLE THREAT.
CONFIDENCENS G .L, T HAPPENEWE
G HAPPENS BECAUSE IT'SSTILL ICTP
RDOR
DA
MOVEDO
ANOFME
HOPENED.HERE, COMING FROM I SHO
TO FLOP.EYEY ARE KINN VER,DEHENL
ALE   DON'T WANT THE
>>NDREY, PRENT PINR IAN GOT
S POINTS SAID IT DOESN'T
ATTENTION OFEST TO0,TRE BORDER H
CONCERNS ABO
WETHL,INATICOESN'T WAN LTO US,OO
HOI THINK THAT IN THE KREMLITH E
UT
IT TRE MILITARY IN ORDER TO DOT
IN
ANRLE THAT
INMORE
COMPLETE IMPLEMENTATION HEK AGRT
LESH BY, ANDREY, IT SEATT WOD S
WEE THATINE THIS MOMEN TTAS WIT
OO TMPLY PEOPLE ON>> WELL, YOE
ADSH TO, ING TO T RUSSI ENCE, A
DONBAS AD IF YOUCAOU
THERE ARE NYAGREEMP IS HAPPE AG.
ARE DETRIMENTA UKRAIAN
SOVEREIGNTY AND TO T